-Thank you, thank you.
Man, just thank you.
I'm happy to be here and not
at home watching "This Is Us."
Uh, I just -- I just
don't want to cry anymore.
I don't want to cry anymore.
It's just a TV show. You get me?
Yeah, it's just a TV show.
Plus I'm happy.
I'm in New York City!
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Laughs ] Yeah!
The greatest city in the world
[ Cheers and applause ]
Is it? Is it? Is it?
[ Laughs ] Is it?
Yeah. Okay.
Here's my Yelp review
on New York City.
Great pizza, good people,
no personal space.
You get me?
Like, I left my hotel
and got touched on
all four sides of my body.
All right? That's not safe
according to Discovery Channel
No, it's not.
If you're in a place
and you get touched
on all four sides of your body
the only way to get out of there
is by shimmying.
You got to shimmy
through the crowd, right?
Till you find a wall.
You put your back on that wall
And then you ride that wall out.
It's survival.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I just taught you something.
You just learned something -
how to survive.
That's who I am now.
That's who I am.
I'm a Yelper. You get me?
Yes, I'm a snitch.
I'm an Internet snitch.
I'm a snitch. I don't care
You're incognito.
No one knows it's you.
I got a picture of a white lad
on my profile.
They don't know it's me.
[ Laughter and applause ]
It doesn't stop --
It doesn't -- So, like
the food better be hot or...
You're getting a whole
paragraph out of me.
It doesn't stop
with Yelp or restaurants.
Social media. Mnh-mnh.
I don't like what you post
Click. I'll report you.
I don't care.
I don't care. What? You star
preaching some hateful stuff
I don't like that.
Click. Reported. You know?
You start using
way too many emojis?
I don't know what that means
Click. Reported.
My fav-- Oh, my --
Oh! My favorite one.
"Felt cute. Might delete later."
Oh, you're showing off.
Click. Reported.
Yeah. Ta--
Yeah, take a month off, Susan.
Take a month off.
[ Laughter ]
My wife -- My wife says
that I'm -- that I'm petty
And I am petty.
I'm petty. I'm petty.
But I'm petty for all of us.
You get me? Yeah.
I'm petty for all of us.
I'll give you an example.
Me and my wife were at the mall,
you know, walking around,
holding hands, pretending
to be happy, right?
And we're happy.
She sees a store window.
And she goes, "Oh, my God!
Look at those jeans
in that store!"
And then I go,
"No, no, let's keep it moving.
That's not --
That store's not for me.
That's not my demographic.
You get me?"
Yeah, I don't shop at stores
where the mannequins
have attitudes.
You get me?
Like, if I go by your stor
and the mannequin's
standing like that?
No, that's not for me.
That's not for me.
Right?
[ Cheers and applause ]
No. Not gonna do it.
"But those jeans
would look great on you!"
And I go, "No, they won't.
No, they won't.
They have holes in the knees
I don't like
showing off my knees."
I've already been poor once.
I don't need to
keep on pretending.
[ Laughter ]
"Go and try them on."
And then I said, "You know what?
I'll listen to you now
so I don't have to
listen to you later."
And I went inside, right?
I find a salesperson.
I go, "Excuse me. Do you hav
those jeans in my size?"
She tells me, "Oh, no.
We don't have THAT size."
It bothered me a little bi
because of the tone
and the volume, you get me
I felt like the whole stor
turned around and looked at me
like, "Who's the Fatty McFat
that can't fit into our jeans?
Right?
But I played it off.
And I say, "Okay, I get it
You ran out of my size.
Thank you for your help."
She jumps right in front of me
and goes,
"Oh, no, you don't get it.
We NEVER have that size."
Whoo! That sound shot out of m
'cause it hurt me.
It -- There was pain, right?
Next thing I know, the old man
that lives inside my soul
came out in the middle
of the store.
"Ah! This is an outrage!"
And I said that.
I wiggled my finger.
Everybody really
looks at me, right?
So I doubled down and I said
"I'm writing an e-mail!"
And I stormed off.
I could have wrote --
I could have wrote the e-mai
on my phone,
but I drove to a public librar
'cause. you know,
I needed the whole computer.
I needed the whole big monitor
with the keyboard.
Like, you're gonna feel each
letter in this angry e-mail.
My wife called me --
"Are you coming back for me?
"Ha ha! You better Uber!"
Two weeks later --
Two weeks later, what happens?
I get a reply. Bing!
A coupon for a free pair
of jeans. You get me?
Yeah. I still can't wear them.
But a win is a win.
A win is a win.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you so much.
I'm Orlando Leyba.
♪♪♪♪
-Oh, my gosh! You did it again
You did it again.
Come on. Orlando Leyba!
[ Cheers and applause ]
For more, follow him --
@heylando.